what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and the next movie we have coming out
from Marvel Studios is the Marvels AKA
Captain Marvel 2 and AKA partly Miss
Marvel season 2. in the Marvels we will
see The Return of Captain Marvel Miss
Marvel Kamala Khan and Monica Rambo the
three of them all having powers and
getting their powers intermingled with
each other and calling themselves the
Marvels and a lot of Marvel fans have
been kind of worried about this movie
Captain Marvel herself isn't the most
beloved superhero in the MCU and Miss
Marvel got mixed reviews although most
people do agree that Aman balani is an
incredible Miss Marvel but hopefully
people are coming around and are pretty
excited to see the marbles when it hits
theaters this year November 10th and it
looks like Marvel Studios has done a new
round of test screenings recently and
today we've heard a little about what
people are saying about what they saw in
the Marvel's test screening whether or
not they liked what they saw or did not
like what they saw we also have another
update about the Marvel's trailer the
final trailer how long it's going to be
and when to expect it exactly so we'll
break down everything you need to know
about the Marvels in this video and if
you're new be sure to subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss out on any of
the latest MCU videos and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month so first and foremost some really
big news about Miss Marvel Marvel
Studios and Disney Plus in general for
Marvel Studios that is it is now
official Miss Marvel's entire first
season is going to air on ABC next month
becoming the first Marvel Studio series
to release on network television now
what's interesting is Bob Iger recently
did some interviews talking about the
future of Disney plus and he did mention
that this is on the table and that they
are considering doing this well looks
like they are doing this and if you're
not aware Disney does actually own ABC
so it's still kind of the same company
all under Disney but Bob Iger mentioned
this and now it's happening and for the
Marvel fans out there it's important to
know that he did also say that they are
going to be cutting back on the Disney
Plus shows so from here on out don't
expect four to six Disney Plus shows a
year plus special presentations or a
short series or anything like that they
are going to be cutting back but it is
kind of cool to see the series going on
other networks however some people are
reading into this taking it as the
marbles is going to suck and it's going
to bomb at the box office and now in
order to prevent that they are putting
Miss Marvel on ABC so people know who
Miss Marvel is so they'll go and watch
the marbles however Insider Casey Walsh
had a response to that today on Twitter
tweeting out the Marvels is one of the
best tested movies to come out of the
studio this year and Iman like Larson is
a huge start in attraction it's going to
do just fine and if anything this is a
great PE Synergy move and I'd expect
more Disney Plus shows to come to ABC
now now to mention that last point there
this is what Bob Iger said like I just
mentioned so yes do you expect more
Disney Plus shows to come to ABC of
course they will probably air on Disney
plus first and remain on Disney plus as
they air on ABC another cool fact if you
haven't heard is that Aman villani the
actress who plays Miss Marble in the MCU
is helping write the new Miss Marvel
Comics which is pretty cool Casey Walsh
mentioned Symmetry and I do like the
Symmetry that could be had between the
MCU and the comics with the actress who
plays Miss Marvel being a part of both
but going back to what KC Walsh had to
say the marbles is one of the best
tested movies to come out of the studio
this year and we had heard in the past
that when they did do test screenings
for the Marvels people were really
liking what they saw now obviously
things change Studios do test screenings
all the time and try to get the input
from the people who saw them so they can
improve the movie they basically asked
them what did you like what didn't you
like were you confused was there a
particular part that needs more
clarification any particular lines that
stood out as just extremely weird or are
there any lines that stuck out in a very
very good way they do all of this of
course to make the movie better so yes
they do ask these questions and do take
what these people say into consideration
now it's also worth noting that the
people who are watching these films
aren't exactly all out fully involved
Marvel Studios fans so you're not
getting a bunch of MCU Lovers Only who
are watching this film stating that it
is great you are getting a mix of a lot
of different people what Disney does is
they send screener information out to
Disney employees they don't even tell
them what movie that they are about to
watch they simply ask if they want to
see a movie of course they have to come
in and sign ndas agreements that say
they won't disclose anything that they
saw and of course no phones or anything
allowed in there as well and then they
watch the movie so some could be Marvel
fans but a lot of them might not be
which is good because you want a
combination of both you want some people
in there who love Marvel and are used to
what Marvel Studios has to offer and so
some who are just casual viewers and now
it looks like they've had a couple of
different test screenings at this point
and each time they've had one it seems
like the reviews for it are really good
and this is a good sign because
hopefully with each viewing they've only
made the movie better and based off of
the first trailer that we saw I'd say
that the movie is looking pretty good so
far as long as they nail the story and
we've heard a lot of different things
about the story and it sounds like there
might be a good Cameo or two in the
movie as well with Nova being rumored
And I stress rumored not confirmed to be
in the movie and maybe even some other
cool characters as well this is a cosmic
film Our Heroes will be traveling
throughout the cosmos and who knows who
else they'll run into in this movie now
hopefully the new trailer will give us a
little bit more of an update on what the
actual story is and like I mentioned we
do have some updated news about the
trailer today coming from the account
cryptic HD quality who has been
reporting about the trailer and other
trailers in the past they State the
upcoming trailer for the Marvels is 2
minutes and 21 seconds long this is
about standard we've seen shorter and
we've seen longer trailers so it's a
decent length but when can we expect to
see the trailer well cryptic HD quality
has stated that the new the Marvel's
trailer has been attached to the Haunted
Mansion which releases July 28th so
that's less than two weeks away however
they also did mention that it could
still release earlier but I would expect
it around the 28th and here's the reason
why the secret Invasion finale is July
26th and we know that the Marvels ties
directly into the events of secret
Invasion on many different levels one
Nick Fury is involved in the Marvels and
he's obviously the main character of
secret Invasion but Carol Danvers her
story is also connected to the scroll so
we do know that the events are going to
be related to Captain Marvel as well her
name has been mentioned many times
throughout the secret Invasion Series in
fact some people think that she might
make a cameo in the finale I would not
expect that the director has already
stated no cameos in the finale it's very
much a series about Nick Fury will all
of these events be mentioned in the
Marvels I'm assuming at least a little
bit but I don't think she's coming in
for secret Invasion now a post-credits
scene could show us a trailer for the
Marvels it wouldn't be the first time
that a Marvel Studios project has done
that it would be the first time at
Disney plus project has done that but
you would imagine that Marvel Studios
wants to wait until after the secret
Invasion finale so that they could
specifically keep the focus on secret
Invasion to keep those Disney Plus
numbers up so it could come the 26th the
very same day could come the 27th the
day after or it simply could come the
28th attached with the Haunted Mansion
of course it could come earlier but like
I mentioned they probably want to keep
the focus on secret Invasion so I'm
expecting it one of those three days but
of course if we hear anything about a
specific release date an actual date
locked in we'll be sure to let you know
so be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos you can also
check us out on patreon you can check
out our website and our Discord server
as well and of course you can follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching wolf
foreign